per tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo incredibile video anche non ho
visto niente ma so già che incredibile
piena di minecraft big vanilla perché
oggi sono con il top designer del mondo
e si chiama quest'uomo ha fatto la cosa
mi ha fatto un regalo più bello che
abbia mai ricevuto mi ha rifatto la casa
di minecraft mi deve tifare ragazzi
perché io nella mia casa vecchia quindi
non so dove vada a finire centro quindi
entra e varia dai vai vai vai o no vado
eccoci qua che chiude gli occhi chiudi
gli occhi e spero guardando anni aiuto
ho preparato una pedana dal quale si può
iniziare
ok guarda mi guardo bene allora vi
vogliamo prenderli mai
ok allora gas e stasera dio fianco di
mai a cristo ma cosa sto vedeva per me
va beh ma sei pazzo ma tu che il lavoro
fai un design di raina reviglio divide
guardo mi fa quanti so quanti diamanti
vuoi che è niente di niente
posso fare cospetto smette il conto
pagamento recensioni cavalli bellissimo
sono lama cenno amico per fernando
chiamavano male amarci per la casa
ma cosa sto vedendo la cosa vedo
sono miei e anche buddy li accoglierò
tantissimo allora adesso che la prima di
entrare delle seguirmi ok devi seguire
perché devi dire la effe l'agilità
lontano giustamente che sennò non sa non
abbonarsi sì certo c'è da ragazzino cosa
sto vedendo cioè io sono emozionato
questo fosse casa mia la rai ma l'hai
capito ok la pedana è fatta ma la
teniamo
e ha però nella reactions e se la pedana
per per rim per guardare ai la casa
eccoci qua a è vero ce l'hai agenzie la
genia catena di notte e fa un effetto
fantasma e ti mando la foto così la fai
mettere in sovraimpressione norma si
passò come ma perché adesso voglio
cambiare un po lo scrive no perché sono
sempre lo stile fantasy così ha dato
oggi facciamo uno steering fermerà certo
certo
bellissimo la casa infernale bellissimo
mi piace un sacco mi piace un sacco di
fare tutto quello che non tutto ma qual
modo posso sdebitarmi mai se vuoi ti
dico quando chi quando sono impressione
chiamata del nostro fare niente di tutto
questo è tutto mio questo più
quest'albero grazie grazie deve un po di
favori quale che spetta spende voglio
godermi lo sapete c'è un interesse poi
devi trovarlo e all'ingresso c'è
un'inter event ci sono 60 200
questo è un alleato da un formato
madonna ma come avete fatto a far male
ma io non c'ero durante li odio ok
proprio nel mezzo anche il video abbiamo
parlato molto di più di quello che
servisse perché siamo sbagliati comunque
e 9 c'è vieni vieni qua qua ra qua c'è
l'ingresso proprio l'ingresso dove tu
puoi lasciare le varie cose non so tipo
perché non mi guarda bene sui lati ok
un cartello lì c'è un cartello pesca
sciroppata ho già sentito questo termine
mi chiamano così grazie va bene dato
perché comunque vada anche poi qua c'è
il tuo lettino carino caruccio poi sono
le cose belle poi andiamo su chi fa
scassare che per salire c'era liana ci
sono andato sun io ho tanto dai
libertari pieni addio la scelta del sito
lei comunque aiuto a ieri a male a yara
vai qua perché dobbiamo andare nello
spazio centrale prima vai va bene ok
perfetto va tutto a posto
basterebbe la signora sistino bellissimo
falsa degli incanti quelli sei falso sei
bellissimo e salina si può salire è
certo e non si lascia niente al caso
ok e ho messo 4 incudini perché tanto
adesso la farm di ferro quindi avevo
tempo di avevo fatto da sprecare
ci ho messo un'ora per farne uno
ma è stato bellissimo che lo sbaglio è
bella anche la parte a questa parte
brutta essersela parte bruttina in satin
vado ok per feraud io questa parte
grossa della effe quasi tutto quello che
sa invece se puoi riempire ma sono le
fornaci per cuocere il cibo veloci nati
così metto qualcosa tipo rimane lì sopra
bellissimo ok ok poi sociali facciamola
parte delle ceste noi ci asteniamo in un
botto è morto
se abbiamo creato cosa incredibile viene
da dio cos'è sto ponte sospeso no vabbè
ragazzina sto male
vedo anche mille vedo anche piazza che
aulenti a milano va in meta di qua
mettete in quell'angolino lì mi sono
messo a ya no eh sì ma tanto si sa molto
di più da quant'è che ci si potra è da
poche avercela da questa o da quella
prima di questa ma perché non avevo la
minima idea ti senti metal gear
bellissimo amico mio che ti devo dire mi
hai fatto una casa stellare madonna si è
bellissimo capitato l'hai fatto
veramente tutti in salvo i ball tutta
tutto tutto tutto tutto sei piloti e ti
faccio vedere qual è stato da chieda
aggiungiamo minuti al video vieni vieni
mi va bene alla domanda house line ok
mesi dello slam e promettente nell'acqua
non mi farò solo staccato tra verona e
divertentissimo rimbalzata uno slam
ok poi scendere poi l'asti dico
praticamente c'è stata una parte che mi
ha tolto solo quella almeno un file non
proverò un'oretta e mezza
ok mi senta vieni sono stato bocciato
cercare ok ok abbia parte il farming che
quello non lo conto ci aveva mai la
catena ok la cala catena ok è questa qua
aspetto che facciamo arrivargli di qua
qua ci arriviamo
la catena ovviamente ho fatto tutta con
gli scaffali che ti porta in aria e
soprattutto vedi queste linee rosse
questi sono fatti in modo che non
crescano più cosa fare sì bisogna
metterlo di kent una stringa vedi chi è
stato in quanto cosa ci sono delle
stringhe non romperlo via niente anzi si
sono per non farle scendono per non
farle scendere stata la cosa più
difficile sta a fare tutte quelle robe
lì e cadenti
bellissima con soste stringhe scusa
ragnatele sono solo schema tipo string
ok ok ragazzi non so che dire ma che
casa stellare belli ce l'ho più grossa
di steppe fair e grazie
ma torno me la sarei mai immaginata così
bella cercando di vendere lettera j
farà una la mia testa c'era fj tutte di
metallo bianco ma no non mi piaceva
l'idea di fare solo due lettere cioè non
era bello così che sei dove non si
vedono mi piace chi sa fernando che cosa
ha visto in tutto sto casino avrà visto
dei lavori in corso così non si sono mai
visti meno male che c'è di due non io
avrei trapanato fatto cose bellissime
sono troppo contestato anche gli alberi
mai fatto cioè il video ha fatto qualche
ajo dai non ho fatto e non ce la faccio
pazzesco pazzesco va beh
amico emilio di tutti i materiali che
sono rimasti sono di boom bel po di
quarzo che tanto avevamo il piccone con
la fortuna di tensione come quando ti
fanno le piastrelle in case ti tieni per
te le tieni per cambiare piastrelle per
bellissimo lavorare veramente fantasy
grazie mille
niente mi sono veramente che dirti
perché è veramente troppo bella
nier la vetrina dello fatto con piacere
a me piace costruire allora ragazzi
questa era la casa che march mi ha
creato dalle marce barbarie ma
discutiamo il merito anche abati che ci
mancherebbe altro anzi devo farli anche
lui un altro pezzo di carne non ce l'ho
secondo te è un pezzo di dirt va bene lo
stesso poi c'è un pezzo di torta e
meglio è meglio guardare un po allora
pulito quello bene sono contentissimo è
anche più alta delle nuvole a quanto
vedo meglio di così non potevo immagino
veramente non mi sarei mai immaginato
rivolgere a parte gli scherzi cioè
pazzesco sono troppo guarda quella di
stefano bontempi guarda guarda team a
cui questo file action alla foto che ti
ha mandato su whatsapp che di notte con
le shaders resta ragazzi è così mamma
migliorino tegole shader è così button
crema veramente non so che dirti sei un
fenomeno ma dall altro che grafica c'è
su minecraft waste e shader attive
sempre no no no queste le marche solo
per fare gli screen e le foto per
instagram ma veramente la casa più
bella che io abbia mai visto cioè sei un
fenomeno bravissimo ragazzi passate
direi tutti su cani di marcia iscrivere
perché lo so in che altro modo
ringraziarlo già aveva fatto robbie il
mondo poi hai fatto tu making of di sta
roba nuovissima di sì sì sì però io lo
guardo io vi do non l'ho fatto per tutta
quindi si vedrà sono il tuo video coppia
è ok ok ok però va beh almeno c'è un
making lo guarda che io viva perché
questa è la mia casa di minecraft nella
big vanilla che ho fatto io nessuno mi
ha dato una mano perché io sono i
costruttori microsoft e nessuno lo può
negare
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
guardate talmente bella che vendono gli
animali vedere troppo bello anche gli
scheletri anno le robe incantate della
serie nuova per non fosse avvicinarci
sono 50 voterò perché qua ci fanno un
mazzo tanto bellissima comunque avere
ragazzi bellissima sta roba sono troppo
contento giuro iamm forse ovino ragazzi
si chiede anche ai lasciate un vi piace
un bel commento e andiamo a sfruttare i
nostri video questa casa mastodontiche
bellissima belle ragazze
[Musica]